over the years dc's artists and writers
have told all kinds of batman stories
and batman himself often changes along
the way but there are a few key aspects
of the character that always stay the
same
almost always at least these are the
rules batman has to follow
it's hard to pinpoint exactly when but
at some point during the last 80 years
the silhouette of the bat became more
closely associated with a dc superhero
franchise than
well actual bats the basic elements of
batman's costume are essential to his
identity in ways that don't necessarily
apply to other
fictional characters for instance hugh
jackman plays wolverine in multiple
x-men movies but doesn't wear his iconic
mask once and that works just fine
because as long as you can see
wolverine's claws you know he's
wolverine
additionally the attitude and mannerisms
define james bond more than any specific
visual cues
but batman needs his batsuit and a big
part of that is the insignia
now there have been a few occasions on
which batman has forgotten the insignia
his insider suit doesn't have it for
example and certain alternate versions
of the character don't use it either but
these are rare exceptions that prove a
very
important rule namely that the big bad
bat symbol is as much a part of the
character as alfred or the batmobile
get rid of it and you might as well be
reading daredevil
as batman knows a good cape can come in
very handy every now and again
beyond the cape's advantages in
hand-to-hand combat however there's also
the fact that it's a crucial part of
looking badass standing on a tall
building in gotham and we all know how
much batman loves to do that
still he doesn't always wear a cape a
terry mcginnis version of the character
doesn't wear one while the future state
version of bruce wayne goes without too
as does that pesky insider suit but even
if he's not sporting a cape there's one
thing the character should always have
a mask with little pointy decorative
ears of course the size and shape of
batman's ears have varied over the years
heck they're barely even visible on
applex suit but they're always there
and while they may not be quite as
iconic as the cape or even the insignia
batman's ears have become a staple of
the hero's design
and they've even gone on to influence a
handful of other super folk over the
years
including catwoman catman daredevil and
black panther
from the unmistakably snazzy effects of
the camping 1960 series to robert
pattinson just straight up laying into a
street thug in the batman
it's clear that bruce wayne has always
been a punchy kind of guy there are a
few good reasons why this has become
such a crucial part of the character
for one there's a basic primal thrill to
be found in it even though fighting
isn't all that fun in real life
fictional combat is exhilarating like
almost nothing else
why else do action movies even exist so
any writer who needs to inject a little
excitement into their batman story
simply needs to provide gotham's
guardian with a pace to punch a stomach
to kick or a limb to snap
and voila instant entertainment have you
ever danced with the devil in the pale
moonlight
[Music]
from batman's in story perspective
criminals might not find him so
intimidating if they knew they stood a
chance against him in a fist fight
so his reputation as a master of several
martial arts disciplines makes it easier
to intimidate potential foes
and also allows him to solve the
majority of his problems with a
well-placed knock to a skull or tent
some of batman's adversaries might be
too powerful to beat up of course
while others might be smart enough to
avoid a punching contest with him
but for your typical everyday purse
snatcher type a haymaker wrapped in a
back glove will always do the trick
and then some they don't call him the
world's greatest detective for nothing
you know
batman might be able to throw a punch
like nobody else but he's just not
batman if he doesn't get the chance to
flex his strongest muscle of all
when bruce wayne first devoted himself
to warring against crime he didn't just
spend the following years honing his
fighting prowess to virtually unmatched
levels
he also developed one of the finest
forensic and scientific minds gotham has
ever known
particularly when dealing with foes such
as the riddler and the joker
it's important to be able to decipher
the clues they usually leave lying
around
batman's powers of detection also come
in very handy when hunting the hordes of
criminals who don't actually want to be
caught too
and sure not every version of batman has
the genius level deduction skills and
access to lab equipment that the
billionaire bruce wayne enjoys
nonetheless they must all keep their
perception sharp and their thinking
sophisticated ready for the next time
they run into a dilemma they can't get
out of with a punch and a kick
in the marvel universe superheroes
usually live in fictionalized versions
of real world cities such as new york
and san francisco
in the dc universe the action does
sometimes take place in or around real
world locations but most stories occur
in made-up municipalities like
metropolis or gotham city
these places play host to a wide variety
of criminals and crime fighters
but while other heroes tend to bounce
around the map batman always resides in
gotham
the movies often copy and paste multiple
urban locations into an amalgam they can
use as gotham with parts of new york
london tokyo chicago
and numerous other towns standing in for
the city and various batman movies
so while gotham looks very distinctive
in some renderings it's more often
depicted as a fictionalized version of
every american city in the midwest and
northeast
and while it may not have the glitz and
glamour of los angeles or the chic east
coast flair of new york it does at least
seem like the kind of place a feller
could open a costume store and do all
right for himself
maybe that's why batman never seems to
want to leave it behind that guy just
can't resist a good freak
at the end of the day most batman
stories come about because companies
like dc and warner brothers want to make
money
and one way of doing that is by mass
producing toys action figures and other
such merchandise
certainly this partly explains why
batman always drives a customized car or
similar bat vehicle but let's not get
too wrapped up in cynicism here after
all unlike some dc heroes batman can't
fly and he's gotta get from place to
place somehow
although it's a near constant feature in
batman's vast canon the batmobile has
taken many different forms over the
years
the heavy duty monstrosity from batman
begins marked a departure from the sleek
stylish vehicle on display in tim
burton's batman and batman returns for
example
and they both look far less hokey than
the one adam west drives in the 60s tv
show
indeed the batmobile appears to change
far more frequently than batman himself
while different characters might take up
the bat mantle every now and then and
the setting occasionally changes to a
different historical era batman's design
has still remained far more consistent
than the ever-changing look of the
batmobile
batman's definitely not your average joe
but he does have a few things in common
with the rest of us
for one he needs a place to keep his
stuff and if he parks a batmobile out in
the driveway of wayne manor well there's
a decent chance that passerbys might put
two and two together
traditionally the bat cave makes a
terrific garage and secret layer but
serves plenty of other purposes too
the batcave is also a crime lab a
training gym a top of the line medical
facility a super computer a costume
design studio and an unofficial trophy
room showcasing keepsakes from batman's
favorite adventures
occasionally it even includes an
obstacle course complete with faux
opponents
similar to the early version of the
danger room in xavier's school for
gifted youngsters
the batcave also provides a natural
habitat for a colony of actual bats
because after all he is called batman
bruce wayne's list of allies is a long
one indeed it could include
any number of individuals formerly or
currently known as robin
multiple crime fighters currently are
formerly known as batgirl
catwoman a few members of the gotham
city police department lucius fox and a
handful of his immediate family members
and of course bruce wayne's longtime
butler alfred pennyworth
and if a mission requires a trip abroad
or off planet he has the rest of the
justice league to call upon for
assistance
even other versions of the character
tend to have friends for example terry
mcginnis primary running buddy in his
future version of gotham happens to be
bruce wayne himself
even the horrifying batman who laughs as
a bunch of creepy vampire type creatures
and robin outfits on
leashes and sure in theory batman works
alone
most likely so he can tell people that
he works alone which is all well and
good for sounding all brooding and
dangerous
but in practice batman usually works
with a big old heap of pals
to some extent this is true of every
major superhero but it's doubly
important for batman as without plenty
of personal connections to keep him
grounded he could end up walking a very
dark path indeed
gadgets are a must-have for any
superhero who doesn't have any actual
superpowers so it follows that batman
has plenty
heck he's even got that iconic utility
belt to carry them all around in
one man's tool is another man's weapon
in your mind perhaps
there aren't many things you can't turn
into enough the police weren't getting
it done
batman's full list of gizmos is pretty
much impossible to count but one thing
that is certain is that as far as
equipment is concerned
it's very rare for him to find himself
caught short it's worth noting that the
exact nature of batman's gadgets really
depends on the tone of the media in
which he's appearing
family-friendly light-hearted versions
of batman tend to load their utility
belts up with unintuitive and even
downright silly accessories
after all who could forget this hand me
down
the shark repellent bat spray
but when it comes to more realistic
spins on batman's story he usually goes
for grappling hooks smoke bombs and not
a whole lot else
occasionally a bat branding iron finds
its way into the mix but we wouldn't
bank on that one becoming a regular
feature in the caped crusaders arsenal
anytime
soon it could very well be that the
deaths of thomas and martha wayne have
been performed on screen more than any
character who wasn't created by william
shakespeare but there's more to the loss
of bruce wayne's parents and hollywood's
over reliance on franchise fare
simply puts batman always needs to
endure a soul annihilating trauma to
kick-start his vendetta against crime
in some interpretations his mission
evolves into a war against suffering and
death itself
other times he just winds up beating up
muggers and serial killers but either
way if nothing bad ever happens to
thomas and martha then batman doesn't
begin
of course bruce wayne isn't the only
batman but this rule extends to
basically every single person who's ever
donned the cape and cowl
before they became bad heroes dick
grayson kate kane
thomas wayne jean-paul valley damian
wayne
and terry mcginnis all lost immediate
family members due to acts of senseless
often random violence
and here lies the true nature of the
caged crusader if all your loved ones
are alive and well then you just can't
be
batman the closest you can come is just
throwing on a costume and fighting crime
which
let's be honest isn't necessarily the
same thing no matter what shape or form
he might take batman is defined by the
tragedy of his origin
and that is the one thing that can never
ever change
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]